what a lovely tropical scene palm tree
coconut and oh hello guy help you we're
appreciating this lovely tropical seed
this is an actual crab it's called the
coconut crab and it grows to an
outlandish nine pounds and three feet
across and get this it's actually a
super sized hermit crab without a shell
basically it's the Hulk version of the
crustaceans you took to show-and-tell in
second grade in fact it's the biggest
terrestrial arthropod on earth this may
actually be as large as physics will
allow that exoskeleton can get heavy so
without the support of water the critter
is fighting a battle with gravity as its
name suggests the coconut crab is pretty
fun of coconuts and is so powerful it
has no problem tearing right through
them it also eats fruits and vegetables
plus the odd carcass here and there and
kittens yeah I said kittens it's really
kittens not this kitten though this
kittens fine
it may go without saying that you
shouldn't get your fingers in the crabs
claws but you shouldn't get your fingers
in the crabs claws one dude who made
that mistake lost feeling in his thumb
for three months which goes - oh coconut
crabs don't appreciate show-and-tell
nearly as much as you and me
you